en quelques secondes la vie de paul et
précis un couple libano canadien a
basculé dans l'horreur le cas trop 2020
leur appartement situé à 1 km du port
est entièrement démolie
[Musique]
la déflagration leur arrachent leur
fille alexandra trois ans
c'est un enfant qui se réveille en
chantant et qui dormait en chantant
alexandra était était vraiment une
amoureuse de ce pays en octobre 2019
drapeau libanais à la main elles
manifesté sur la place des martyrs ou
encore dans les rues du centre ville
sa mort a fait d'elle le symbole d'une
révolte populaire contre une crise qui
ne cesse d'empirer l'électricité le gaz
l'eau potable sont devenus des produits
de luxe
les denrées de base ne sont plus
subventionner même le prix des
médicaments a bondi ce marchand affirme
qu'un de ses poissons vaut le salaire
d'une journée de travail je ne peux rien
acheter ajoute cette mère de trois
enfants
vous voyez des gens fouiller dans les
ordures pour trouver quelque chose à
manger renchérit ce libanais on a une
classe politique qui a conduit ce pays à
la faillite à la direction en face des
crises économiques et bancaires et de
dette
et en plus de ça on a maintenant une
crise politique avec une capacité de
former un gouvernement dont le moment où
on a besoin de plus
résultat la livre libanaise a perdu 80%
de sa valeur
le taux d'inflation est de plus de 130%
le pouvoir d'achat est anéanti au regard
des chiffres ont voté des taux de
pauvreté de plus de 55% de la population
et ça c'est un pays qu'on disait
quelques années c'est l'astuce de
lorient
l'aco vide a attisé la colère de la rue
le gouvernement qui a imposé un
confinement n'a apporté aucune aide
économique aux libanais alors ce qu'on
voit les mouvements qui se passe à
tripoli à beyrouth ce sont plus des
mouvements contre un système politique
mais ce sont les mouvements autres la
fin dans le quartier h la fille est à
beyrouth cette association des fils au
confinement pour nourrir 6500 personnes
chaque jour
nous sommes un peuple presque orphelins
donc tout ce que le gouvernement est
censés faire nous les ong nous sommes en
train de le faire à leur place
mais que non et je ne peux pas remplacer
un gouvernement
les parents d'alexandre à désespère
d'une possible justice mais pour leur
fille ils veulent continuer à se battre
pour pouvoir maintenir l'héritage de
l'ex auxerrois pouvoir je ne pense pas
qu'on pourra avoir des enfants dans ce
pays parce que ça serait trop risqué la
seule liberté qui reste selon des
résidents de beyrouth et celle ci le
choix entre mourir dhofar et mobiles
doro vivent ici hasmik rails at radio
canada montréal